[Musica]
quante volte mia madre mi ha urlato
elena metti a posto qui è tutto
sottosopra
naturalmente si riferiva alla mia camera
che era totalmente disordini in
disordine proprio un disastro totale
ecco anche oggi che sono madre di due
figli che sono sposata mantengo una sana
attitudine al disordine
a volte mi chiedo quando guardo le
riviste nel mio settore del design se le
case che che vediamo tutte patinate
perfetto e asettiche quasi esistano
veramente e se esistono davvero ma chi
ci vive veramente qualcuno e me lo
chiedo perché io non potrei restare
sentirmi a mio agio in un ambiente dove
tutto sembra seguire un unico ordine mi
mancherebbe qualcosa mi mancherebbe
proprio l'energia mi mancherebbe la vita
quando parlo di disordine di sottosopra
di caos non mi riferisco ovviamente solo
una maglietta fuori posto o a un jeans
sul pavimento
mi riferisco ai miei disegni
questo è uno dei miei disegni sono
disegni molto carichi pieni di di
textures ed i dettagli questo caos che
poi mi caratterizza
anni fa ho fatto una ricerca e ho capito
che potrebbe trattarsi di di horror
vacui ovvero la la paura del vuoto degli
degli spazi liberi
effettivamente il vuoto mi ha sempre
terrorizzata mi mi fa proprio sentire
sola e se potessi prendere la mia matita
e inizierà a riempire tutti vuoti che
esistono
ecco quando però mi trovo davanti a un
foglio bianco
forse non ci crederete ma per un attimo
mi paralizzo sento proprio una
sensazione di di paura di sgomento poi
prendo la mia matita e inizia a dar
sfogo ai miei pensieri ai miei bisogni e
proprio come un vulcano con il fuoco
dentro inizio a sentire tutta la
creatività che mi esplode sotto le dita
ecco io ho sempre disegnato fin da
piccola già molto piccolo ero una
bambina molto timida e anche paurosa e
lui a disegnare probabilmente come una
terapia era proprio il mio modo per
evadere dalla realtà per per star bene
dico probabilmente perché è stato tutto
molto inconsapevoli consapevole senza
guide ho consigli da parte di nessuno
e ho così iniziato a disegnare tutti i
personaggi tutti quei mostri questi
animali un po bizzarri mostri che
animavano il mondo della della mia
fantasia e piano piano negli anni oltre
avermi fatto capire proprio quale fosse
la mia assenza il mio linguaggio
artistico sono diventati degli amici dei
veri compagni di viaggio ecco trasmutare
le mie paure in linguaggio artistico
esattamente quello che ho fatto
quando disegnavo tutto il mondo fuori
tutte le paure sparivano mi tuffavo
totalmente in un'altra dimensione
come vi dicevo ero molto timida ed ero
spesso sola non stavo sempre a casa da
sola e non mi piaceva parlare però avevo
il mio foglio avevo il mio foglio che mi
aiutava e quando entravo in questi mondi
faccio delle magie addirittura me mi
inventavo delle personalità diverse
delle storie e da da timida e paurosa
diventato invece molto estroversa
coraggiosa cosa è coraggiosa riuscivo
proprio a capovolgere da sola tutto il
mio mondo e ancora oggi lo faccio quando
disegno torno là sotto nella mia bolla
di cristallo fuori tutto il mondo touch
è il mio mondo interiore inizia a
parlare
la cosa singolare è che non ho non
disegnavo solo su tela anzi preferivo
disegnare soggetti che potevano essere
vasi piuttosto che vecchie scatole o
mobili sono sempre stata attratta dagli
oggetti e d'altra parte il mio lavoro e
disegnare oggetti perché ho sempre
pensato che fossero il modo migliore
per raccontarsi mi piaceva l'idea che
questi oggetti entrassero nelle case
delle persone e passassero da casa in
casa da nonna nipote che potessero
raccontare le storie delle case
precedenti e delle vite precedenti
probabilmente volevo disegnare su
oggetti
industriali di di uso comune proprio per
entrare in più casi è possibile
raccontare la mia storia più persone
possibili ed è proprio per questo che ho
scelto di fare la designer
arrivata all'università però mi sono
trovata davanti alla regola madre al
diktat a quale attenersi quando si fa
design sottrarre ridurre all'essenza
eliminare l'inutile il famosissimo less
is more di messiniana memoria e voi
potete immaginare solo immaginario come
mi sono sentita malissimo morto e ci ho
provato non che non ci abbia provato
come vedrete in queste prossime immagini
a modo mio però ci ho provato d'altra
parte i maestri ci stavano insegnando
questo all'università mi stava
insegnando questo e tutto intorno a me
ei miei colleghi parlavano di metodi di
regole di di schemi
non dico che fossero sbagliati e io
queste regole le ho apprese le ho fatte
miele o studiate trovo che soprattutto
studiare se è importantissimo se non
saremo neanche qui a parlarne però come
diceva picasso impara le regole da
professionista per poi romperle come un
artista ed è quello che ti ho cercato di
fare quindi mentre studiavo e mi
atteneva queste regole rigide rigide
regole
ho proprio capito che chi le aveva
decise che le aveva scritte l'aveva
fatto perché lo faceva stare bene perché
si ritrovava in quei comportamenti e lo
faceva lavorare meglio però quelle
regole
non facevano stare bene me per quanto
valide corrette non erano valide per me
erano solo la parte della torta ed era
una parte della torta in cui io non mi
ritrovavo ho fatto e avevo proprio
bisogno di fare qualcosa di rimettere
tutto sottosopra e di far parlare
soprattutto quella bambina timida e
piena di sogni che aveva bisogno di
esprimersi e così lo liberata
se nel mio lungo percorso di studi ho
imparato veramente qualcosa quel
qualcosa è che il design è disegnare per
far star bene le persone per migliorare
la vita delle persone la mia la tua la
nostra però per fare questo da designer
e avevo bisogno prima di migliorare la
mia di vita e quindi disegnare qualcosa
che mi rispecchiasse appieno ed è così
che un giorno deciso che le regole
imposte per me non potevano buffon più
funzionare e sono tornata a fare quello
che sapevo fare meglio quindi mischiare
tutte le carte creare un po di
confusione di disordine e di rimettere
tutto sottosopra e come ho fatto ho
preso tutto ciò che amavo di più la moda
la pittura i colori pieni di energia le
texture gli animali l'arte e ho creato
un po del mio personale casino che ha
iniziato ad aggiungere aggiungere
attenzione però le aggiunte per me non
sono decori applicati a caso giusto per
rendere più appetibile carino un oggetto
no sono delle stratificazioni necessarie
che servono a raccontare con più forza
il prodotto proprio la storia del
prodotto è poi iniziato a guardarmi ho
capito che anch'io mi ero già guardata
prima naturalmente però con un occhio
diverso e ho capito che io stessero
tutta colorata texturizzato piena di
simboli di anelli è il mio lavoro è
totale espressione di quel che sono io
di me stessa non c'è trucco e non c'è
inganno non c'è niente ricostruito in
quello che faccio il mio lavoro parla di
me e finalmente stava veramente parlando
di me ero io
allora ho preso tutti quei personaggi
tutti quei mostri che abitavano nel
mondo della mia fantasia e li ho
letteralmente strappati dalla tela
quindi sono diventati dal bi
dimensionale del foglio della tela a
tridimensionali sono diventati veri
reali sono diventati dei mobili
piuttosto che vedi oggetti o portato
delle immagini per farvi capire di che
cosa sto parlando
i tre che vedete sotto sono dei vasi in
ceramica che ho disegnato io e tre sopra
li conoscerete sono sempre loro ma è lo
schizzo dal quale sono partite vedrete
tutte le le linee grafiche le texture
dei disegni che vi ho mostrato prima
solo che adesso tutte queste
texturizzazione sono vere sono reali
sono diventati vivi che per me è
qualcosa di magico naturalmente oppure
quest'altro esempio che è un'altalena
gilet in pelle che si ispira a una
canzone di frank zappa che parla di una
medusa immortale
ho il mio mobile credenza è un cabinet
polifemo si chiama e di metallo ed è
inutile che vi dica che lo schizzo dal
quale sono partita e questo io me lo
immaginavo così questo ciclope molto
corpulento con queste gambettine magre e
così l'ho voluto riprodurre ed è
diventato vivono con questo grande
occhio centrale che poi è la maniglia
del mobile
ecco per me è importantissima l'emozione
che generano di oggetti perché per me è
l'oggetto all'anima e come dico sempre
l'emozione è una funzione a tutti gli
effetti del dell'oggetto non è stato
facile per me farmi riconoscere nel
mondo del design intanto per il mio
particolare linguaggio e poi perché non
ho avuto nessun aiuto non avevo
conoscenze posso veramente dire di aver
fatto tutto da sola però nel 2017 e ho
vinto un importantissimo e premio del
salone del mobile come miglior designer
emergente che è un premio
importantissimo proprio per il premio in
sé ma per me lo era perché la giuria
conosceva la capacità di aver introdotto
un nuovo linguaggio che era il mio
linguaggio all'interno del design che
una sorta di neo primitivismo mixato
all'iper decorativismo che poi è insomma
caratterizza anche i giorni nostri e
quindi oggi dopo tanti anni di fatica di
di studio di duro lavoro e sono per la
quarta volta consecutiva ambasciatrice
dell'italian design nel mondo e di
questo naturalmente ne vado molto molto
fiera
tirando le somme posso dire grazie
grazie
tirando le somme posso dire che la mia
fortuna se così vogliamo chiamarla sia
stata quella di di ribellarmi di non
seguire le regole gli schemi e di
impormi con grande coraggio e anche un
pizzico di incoscienza e di far parlare
questi mondi interiori che poi sono
diventati arte in questo esempio sono
addirittura entrata nelle mie
installazioni artistiche quindi sono
entrata come nei miei disegni
fisicamente grazie a queste
installazioni
ecco con il mio discorso non voglio dire
che il caos il disordine siano la legge
che guida il mondo anche se qualcuno
prima di me lo ha fatto però voglio dire
che per chiunque si occupi occupi di
sperimentazione di ricerca e di
innovazione come per il mio lavoro
ecco arriva un momento in cui tutto
sembra fermo sembra che non ci siano più
soluzioni che tutto sia in stallo quello
il momento di cercare di spingersi oltre
di cambiare le regole per crearne di
nuove e mettere tutto sottosopra
non abbiate paura di spingervi oltre
e proprio di modificare i vostri punti
di vista le vostre certezze più radicate
perché non basta essere
talentuosi bisogna essere curiosi e non
smettere mai di seguire i propri sogni
esiste un sano sottosopra che ci
permette di sovvertire le regole per
affermare il nostro linguaggio nel mondo
grazie
vagando per la sala mi sono imbattuto in
una borsetta è sì so se vuoi qualcosa a
che vedere con questa borsetta qui la
borsetta la borsetta vedesse qualcuno di
voi al testo e che si può anche guardare
se capisco bene tutto sottosopra
naturalmente vedrete è nata questa idea
di bene va bene quando mi avete chiamata
per insomma per il ted e ovviamente come
questo è un po riassunto in tanto del
del mio del mio talk perché io ho
iniziato ovviamente disegnando
liberamente perché non sono brava con le
parole e sono prati da subito dal tema
sottosopra quindi poi vedrete questa è
una ragazza una qualsiasi ragazza che
potrebbe essere chiunque di voi e che
però da una parte e donna ma kv
capovolgendola diventa un leone il leone
naturalmente no simboleggia la forza nel
re della foresta con la sua criniera e
ci vuole ricordare sempre di di rompere
queste regole con grande coraggio però
mai in modo aggressivo sempre con un
sorriso come fa lei e soprattutto son
contenta perché con questa vi porterete
a casa un pezzettino del mio talk e io
sono onorato di questa cosa grazie alle
mazze
[Applauso]
[Musica]